ab jetzt ein intellektuelles problem da
man von ihnen eine sehr kämpferische
rede gehörte der sie sagten sie würden
die nächste regierung bilden sie haben
gleichzeitig ist es eine große koalition
wird es nicht geben
sie haben gehört wie herr westerwelle
ausgeschlossen hat dass er mit ihnen
koalieren und mit herrn bisky das haben
sie auch gesagt wollen sie nicht jetzt
weiß ich nicht wie sie eine regierung
bilden
ist doch klar herr von der thannen ich
meine ihr intellektuelles problem in
allen ehren aber hier ist doch deutlich
geworden dass die demokratischen
parteien miteinander reden können und
miteinander reden müssen
das wird auch geschehen unabhängig von
dem was jetzt hier geklärt erklärt
worden ist
und da ist es nun einmal so dass die ihn
in die eine regierung bilden könnten
wenn man von den realitäten der
außenminister darauf hingewiesen ausgeht
nicht auf dieser seite sitzen also
werden wir aber anders wir müssen sie
doch mal sagen da müsste doch frau
merkel mal sagen ob sich vorstellen kann
mit einer koalition zu regieren
die besteht aus herrn westerwelle und
den nachfolgern von herrn fischer das
kann ja wohl nicht ernst aber die frau
bundes nach folgen sondern natürlich mit
den nachfolgern im amt des
parteivorsitzenden
also noch nicht im amt des außenminister
also ich sage ihnen glauben sie im ernst
dass meine partei auf ein
gesprächsangebot von frau merkel bei
dieser sachlage eingänge in dem see sagt
sie möchte bundeskanzlerin werden
immerhin müssen kirche auch mal im dorf
lassen dem rad schlägt die deutschen
handels idealer deutschen hand auch in
der kandidatenfrage eindeutig votiert
das kann man doch nicht ernsthaft
bestreiten die deutschland können sofern
sein
ich sage ihnen ich führe gespräche und
ich sage ihnen heute voraus die werden
erfolgreich sein wenn frau merkel eine
koalition hinkriegt mit der fdp und den
grünen dann kann ich dagegen nichts
sagen das werde ich auch nicht tun aber
sie wird keine koalition unter ihrer
führung mit meiner sozialdemokratischen
partei hinkriegen das ist eindeutig
machen sich da gar nichts vor